hola que tal buenas noches pues que
fuera del ordinaria los puedo decir que
me hemos gildardo
ya con eso tienen todo entonces utiliza
la técnica de decir pues que me llamo
hill porque gildardo se me quedaban
viendo en la recepción con carita de si
se demora gildardo o entendí mal yo
entonces mejor látigo hill y que se
queden con la idea de que mejor me llamo
gilberto es mucho más fácil
que más salir de lo ordinario que me
dedico a las ventas hace 20 años 25 años
más o menos y me decidí por el stand up
comedy entonces alrededor de 34
presentaciones que tú dije pues creo que
me verá muy bien
salir de lo ordinario para platicarles
máximo les la experiencia en la primera
persona esta que ven aquí
y me queda muy bien el tema de los x de
los 10 porque más o menos de está
preparada esta rutina
y quiero decirles que pues no se
emocionen mucho los millennials si es
que hay uno por aquí porque yo también
tuve una red social y era el tío gamboín
el que no mandará su cartita para el tío
dominen el loser más grande del mundo y
si no decía tu nombre en la televisión
es como si no te pagaran y te ponen un
like igualito igualito
entonces pues ya después de eso se
evolucionó y pasarlo me preguntaron oye
hill qué sabes de las redes y pues dije
pues las redes son lo que defiende mucho
ahorita en el mundial
me seno de las sociales
a las sociales pues es una materia que
todavía deben preparar el diseño de las
redes sociales dije a las que utilizan
cosas como para poner ahí de me acabo de
levantar no está bien felicidades
o un desayuno ahorita para deportes algo
por mí y waj o lo convoca quien frente y
me lo como
eso ponen una foto o no le faltan un
cuate que viene de poeta y dice que me
dirías hoy si me fuera a morir mañana
eso le pondría usted en cuidado mañana
que tuviera más o menos cuidado si cruza
la calle o algo así
estos x en las cosas en 6 pulgadas
nuestro tamaño 2000
los millennials en este tamaño nosotros
los x salíamos al parque y corrimos como
burros ahí nos quedamos y pues ellos no
ven aquí chiquito y tú pides ayuda a tu
hijo y voltea y mis hijos es de verdad
mi papá cómo es posible que esté rico no
sepa conectar la interfase del google
chrome a la pantalla y tuvo el que
felices vive el teléfono de la casa
así de fácil
con eso los mates así ha sido fácil
los juegos para tener canicas
carreterita no abrir los juegos son en
línea pues en mis tiempos líneas ya
perdidas ya su perdidas usadas línea
fuera sacaban del juego ya no pues ahora
no los controles son muy fáciles en mi
época un botón y una palanquita ahora
son el botón de arriba el botón de abajo
la equis el cuadrado el círculo el
triángulo parece que estás jugando
twister con los dedos sacabas así llegas
todo bien no acabas así todo en tu mismo
eso es como los x como nosotros
trabajamos al menos yo con millenials y
tengo hijos zetas imagínense la
revoltura que la tenés entonces tenemos
que poner de acuerdo todos para poder
hacer las cosas y ahora voy a contestar
una cosita para ccoo porque compramos
cinco veces las mismas las cosas que
editamos porque si no nos hacen ir al
supermercado cuatro veces más porque se
acabaron por eso lo hacemos
más fácil
los niños te piden 250 pesos para
comprarse un café en el starbucks
y el café es una cosa monstruosa con
ingrid ha batido chochitos popotes bueno
poco tengo porque se enojan los de la
condesa
bueno entonces lo ven de colores del
unicornio fi lo tomas y para mí de
verdad están muy a ustedes les gustará
tanto les gusta que lo dejan ahí y
tienen una colección de vasos del lunes
del martes y miércoles y hacen la suma y
son como 1500 press a las semanas de
puros cafés pero bueno en mi época si no
me lo acababa que te decía el papa los
cuántos niños hay sin comer afuera no
hay niños que no tienen papás que les
compren las cosas lo pediste superséis
pues ahora está súper friegas y te
locales al menos si me dicen
las fiestas como eran las fiestas antes
pues nosotros agarramos de árbol a árbol
en chapultepec son más o menos 60 pues
de aquí para acá con globos jorge ahora
no las fiestas son llegan se ven y no se
hablan así que en paraditos no vayas
entonces pues ya no tienen novias ya no
tienen novios ya son jefes o
y un papá x2 piensa que la mujer es como
un curso de regularización de inglés de
la maya lin o boial veces
está bien está bien saca 10 por lo menos
mal pues no alguien sabe qué quiere
decir viejas
o sea en mis tiempos no los tiempos mis
amigos eran super vacaciones y luego
fidencio
esa eran mis amigos ahora no entonces
estas reflexiones más o menos para si
ustedes tienen alguna intención que
hacer afuera que les nazca para hacer
cosas diferentes hagan las en verdad hay
muchas más oportunidades de lo que
tenemos enfrente hay muchas más cosas
que podemos hacer
para poder hacer lo que a nosotros nos
gusta yo que me dedico a las ventas se
los prometo que tengo el no tatuado aquí
en la frente porque nadie quiere nada
cuál es mi intención hacer los que digan
que sí
entonces tengo que buscar diferentes
opciones y a lo mejor esto me está
sirviendo a mí para encontrar diferentes
tipos de personas a las cuales llegarle
diferente tipo manera para que me diga
que sí y si me da el portazo en la cara
los meto por la ventana y si me cierra
la ventana pues me meto por la chimenea
como santacruz y si me prende la
chimenea
pues ya mejor no es por fuera que salga
ya mejor le pido cositas a ver si no
puede echar la mano
entonces
en verdad los x los millenials los 10
hasta me tuve que comprar yo solo la
camiseta porque ponerme la compraba yo
mismo me digo que soy el mejor papá del
mundo por lo menos eso creo
por lo menos eso queremos hay que
convivir estas ya no hay y joe es x y m
zetas y vienen los ases o investiguen
los los hammers hay que ver lo que es
agárrense papas
agárrense entonces esto es para que
convivamos todos the different con las
maneras de pensar pero ponernos
realmente como deben de ser las cosas en
el en la casilla que nos corresponde
nosotros los x les voy a decir que
estamos de moda otra vez vamos a
resurgir porque cuantos nos salen con la
novia del novio y les preguntan oye cómo
te fue en tu cita hay x
ya estamos resurgiendo otra vez hoy ayer
vestido te quedó bien x
entonces vamos resurgiendo las
generaciones van y vienen y se toman
cosas desgraciadamente estamos como que
luego tomando lo que es más fácil
nosotros tuvimos que luchar mucho y
ahorita los chavos os necesitan tiempo
para las redes sociales para pasear el
perro para ir a la fonda ecofriendly
donde les preparan las cosas
hidropónicas no es lo que se comer y te
llegaba de trabajar mi mamá ya había un
sobre de arroz vacía y se quedaba turbo
te lo traga vas porque no había de otra
ahorita no tenemos mucho más cuidado en
eso
la calabaza cuesta 500 pesos porque es
orgánica hidropónica del valle de toluca
donde sé
todo está más bonito entonces es la
reflexión de césar los invito a que
ustedes hagan lo que les nazca a que
ustedes de verdad
pueden hacerlo si yo pude
no soy einstein y creo que tengo un
poquito del -10 del cerebro
pero si de verdad si se puede ser los
firmo que si los jefes las x las 10 los
ms los ases los zetas conviven siempre
se los juro hay que convivir y otra cosa
les digo que también averiguó un poquito
la etimología de mi nombre
gildardo quiere decir sí
pero con hd medio raro escandinavo se
quiere sí hermano
tardo
jardón que también quiere decir fuerte
mano fuerte yo no sé mi esposo porque se
llama claudia porque debe de ser el
revés
buenas noches gracias
[Aplausos]